For this quiz, you're going to be putting your name and
your role to the top of your resume using the same technique James just used.
You'll start by replacing %data% in
HTMLheaderName and HTMLheaderRole with your name and your role.
In this case, the role is the type of job your looking for.
So for me, I would have Web Developer.
You can find the strings HTMLheaderName and HTMLheaderRole within helper JS.
Once you're done, you will either append or prepend the formatted name and
formatted role to the page header.
Now, append adds something to the end of HTML.
While prepend adds something to the beginning of HTML.
For this quiz, you might need to experiment with append and
prepend to get a feel for both of them.
Once you see your name in roll appear on the page correctly, check this box.
And when you do it right, your resume should look something like this.